dude what if Isis is like really good on
the YouTube short algorithm no they got
sick thumbnails they're like dude top
three reasons why you should be an Isis
oh [__] I love lists
[Music]
just to catch us up to speed on some
stuff that is apparently happening the
Supreme Court is about to have two major
cases that could transform the way that
we interact with the internet uh-oh so
next week this has to do with blockchain
[__] no it doesn't actually I should U.S
Supreme no it doesn't thank you keep
guessing
uh Zuckerberg possibly not really Matrix
um torrenting streams no no it's coming
back
comment it's not the one um Joe you got
one huh also not it okay so next week
the U.S Supreme Court said to your two
major cases involving big technology
companies with key aspects of the
internet on the line with its rulings
later this year first up on February
21st and 21st is Gonzalez versus Google
the underlying lawsuit was filed by the
family of an American woman nohimi
Gonzalez who was killed in a 2015 ISIS
attack in Paris the family alleges that
Google which owns YouTube is liable
because its algorithms promoted
extremist content to people likely to be
susceptible to it this case looks at
weather section 230 of the
communications decency act provides
protection for an internet platform's
automated recommendations go Google
argues that it has immunity under the
statute because Isis not YouTube was the
creator of the videos quote section 230
is the foundational law of the modern
internet it was devised in 1996 to
encourage the development of Internet
platforms that would facilitate speech
shit's getting hairy how did Thomas pass
away did they get killed by ISIS or they
they joined Isis and then it says who
was killed in a 2015 ice attack in Paris
either way so they're an American eating
croissants in Paris and they got
attacked by ISIS so that's where it gets
weird right because all the Facebook
stuff may get political but we need
regulations somewhere right you don't
want every kid to be able to YouTube how
to make a nuclear bomb and make one in
the garage but where is that line yeah
that is scary nuclear bombs
over here okay we got that down the
question now boils down to should tech
companies control speech right because
if Isis opens and uploads a video and
they deem that inappropriate what if
someone views
yeah yeah and to answer that earlier
question she was killed at one of the
restaurants struck by terrorist attacks
uh yeah in France yeah because the
regulation happens by a biased regulator
right I almost feel like what we're
talking about is kind of separate I
agree with you Mike but then uh is this
person or this court case almost blaming
Google for the Paris attack because I
think they're like kind of like yeah
they are I think they are calling them
they're saying that they promote Isis
because the Isis messages are allowed to
live on YouTube If Isis wasn't on
YouTube this person would still be alive
perhaps they're saying that their lack
of Regulation is the reason why it
helped play things like ISIS group grow
and then so because Isis grows now you
know they're recruiting and then maybe
they recruited someone that would carry
out these attacks and then they're
they're blaming Google overall for not
for for letting these type of things
exist the algorithm promoting more of
what they looked for yeah before Isis
there was a time when Isis promotion
like uh recruitment videos was going all
over YouTube yeah
so in a related case here's the second
one just to give us more context on this
like you said very kind of murky
conversation here in a related case the
Supreme Court will hear oral arguments
on February 22nd in Twitter versus tomna
relatives of nara's al-assah who was
killed in a 2017 Isis related attack in
Istanbul argue that Twitter Google and
Facebook should be held legally
responsible alleging that Isis used the
platforms to recruit members and that
the tech companies didn't do enough to
curb their extremist users
Twitter argues that the Lower Court
ruling created a quote statute of
impossible breadth saying that
businesses like Banks and rental car
companies would also be liable if a
judge found that they could have done
more to eradicate terrorists using those
Services isn't this interesting because
the exact same arguments going on Big
Time opposite
that Twitter's too Regulatory and
YouTube's too regulatory right to be
biased but these people want them to be
more regulatory yeah and and it's the
same idea like yeah Democrat Republican
argument could be just as serious to
some depending on what actions people
take it's like how they talk about the
Insurrection how they're like that
wouldn't have happened if you hadn't
allowed them to organize on your
platform right well I mean that's what's
going on on Twitter right now because
the the mat tabibi guy he's the the
Twitter files that are coming out
they're showing how the FBI was working
with the Democratic party to silence I
guess right-wing or even not right wing
fully but just conservative foreign
conservative stuff too and then all of
that was getting and then like covet
information they wanted to control it
and um silence people that were
legitimate scientists that had questions
and so they're coming out with all of
this stuff like on a daily basis showing
how the government and Twitter at the
time were working together on on
silencing people that were opposing the
popular thought
so that kind of stuff is interesting
because I'm like should government
control what we read and what they think
is responsible information right or
should it be up to the people to read
this information and choose for
themselves because that's what I think a
democracy should be is the citizens
should be you know it's free information
and we choose whether you know we want
to believe this or that or whatever
versus them thinking oh you know what I
think that this is better for you I
don't disagree with you but the issue
becomes the person with the biggest
wallet will be able to be the biggest
voice and I think that's happening right
now no it is it is it is but it just
depends what voice we want to regulate
or not because yeah what Russia can
throw dollars and buy a million Bots and
tell us whatever we want to say and so
based on us and I was even complaining
to Bart the other day about how Twitter
changed right and you can get a verified
Thing by paying five bucks back in the
day I would more likely trust a verified
thing because I'm like oh this guy's
probably some type of journalist or some
type of academic something but now every
motherfucker's got a thing and they're
all talking about trains in Hawaii but
don't we also I think to Joe's point I
also means but we have to be in control
of our ears no for sure but we but we're
not in control of our ears so like let's
say Isis has a billion dollars and they
make all YouTube videos about how they
should join or whatever
isn't there some sort of also personal
responsibility of what I consume and
whether or not I believe in it or I take
action for sure yeah yeah but what
source would you check if Isis let's
take this for example buys every media
every year because they have the biggest
wall and the most connections online so
all you are seeing and it doesn't say
Isis says let's go to war right it's
[__] Barbara from Michigan right
because they bought that and Barbara's a
safe name nowadays so so they buy you a
safe American name so they buy they buy
them the Google right because we all
know you can pay to get your link at the
highest on Google they buy Twitter they
buy all this so when I go to fact check
I'm also reading Isis yeah but you're
you're explaining Legacy Media and some
no 100 million now no that's what yeah
no it's happening right yeah like Pfizer
all those guys that's how they do it my
point is that you can't control your
ears and you can't fact check because
when you go to fact check it's also them
yeah you just have no idea you have no
[__] it's like what happened to
Snopes yeah
Oh by who I forgot who bought it but
it's advisor it's they sold out you know
what I mean this is also like I'm just
scared because I can't fact check plus
everybody just saw that recent thing
about like AI recreating Joe Rogan on
Tick Tock to like basically sell some
[__] Amazon products yeah it's crazy
and like we're we're obviously at the
[__] breaking point of like AI being
a mass understood concept crazy billions
of dollars are getting poured into this
thing from an investment point of view
now because things like chat gbt have
gone off the wire so crazy and it's like
we're at the tip of the iceberg of what
AI is really about to do no it already
does right so they gave us the dumb
version yeah they got a version that's
that same question again though like
what does it mean to like pay attention
to these platforms and understand what
the truth is because even the people
that maybe we uh took as truth not just
like the ice is buying out like the
Google ad and [__] first part but
it's also the people literal people that
maybe we perceive as truth speakers
right getting AI recreated somehow
finding its way another platform and
then it's like like you know what I mean
not everybody's gonna be a [__]
detective yeah no and you can't is my
point even if you want a detective and
spent all day trying to research
something you can't get an answer
because I've looked into this train [__]
and I've looked at all this the balloons
that's true you have no clue bro that's
that's really true you can know anytime
you you talk about the news I always
catch myself going but I don't know yeah
because you really don't know or you try
to at least go to some old school [__]
but the legacy is [__] up too you're
like well New York used New York Times
used to be legitimate yeah you're like
oh well CNN said but I don't I think
bezels just owns Washington Post now
right now everyone owns everything
exactly so and then and then whether
they may not be politically driven
they're money driven and they probably
have lobbyists and other companies that
they're trying to you know so it's
either going to be political and power
driven or money driven and now you're
[__] so I'm moving to an Island by
myself seriously in a closer look a
closer look at the Gonzalez V Google
case uh in terms of understanding what
the plaintiffs are arguing
um what the plaintiffs argue is that
automated recommendation services are
the active Twitter or Google or Facebook
and they are distinct from the bad acts
of the speakers themselves in this case
Isis so section 230 should not cover the
recommendation in these cases even if it
covers the publication of that material
they're blaming the algorithm yeah in
essence right the the case arises out of
tragic terrorism events in Paris and the
family of one of the victims sued the
internet Platforms in this case YouTube
for what they say is recommending videos
potentially to individuals who might
have been motivated they're there by
kind of radicalizing them Google argues
of course that Google has policies
against terrorist content it's automated
and human moderation systems are not
perfect so it's possible that some
terrorist content was recommended
accidentally by its systems accidentally
but Google says that it's a good video I
mean it's accidental acts and these
events is very tenuous and at that level
if this connection is enough a lot of
Humanity's failures will be laid at the
feet of Internet platforms legal defense
in this context on Section 230 is that
it covers internet Publishers and one of
the key things that Publishers do is
recommend they filter choose decide and
prioritize what to publish and what not
to publish the act of sorting among
various items is a core Act of
Publishers and that is exactly what
section 230 protects internet companies
from being held liable for yeah that's
like can you can you blame phone
companies for like having drug dealers
terrorists like I mean it's just a
service that we all use yeah so but as
far as pushing more content out that's
the hard part it has been a conversation
obviously since you know I mean [__]
the elections with Trump like yeah say
uh seven years ago now yeah that's where
it's a little different than phones
right because because they do have a
recommended which they can control if
they want dude what if Isis is like
really good on the YouTube short
algorithm no they got sick thumbnails
and they're like dude top three reasons
why you should be in Isis
oh [__] I love lists which is the
Morongo theme song you have you guys
seen those videos no I haven't it's it's
modern it's they use it like actual
cinematographers really they're their
videos are really good they are no I
swear to God they are well produced I've
heard people say the Isis of videos are
like I was shocked good cinematography
because also Vice did this whole thing
on um Western country folks joining Isis
right which is so good like people who
grew up in like England all that stuff
they would move and they became Isis
followers and then they would play these
clips and there's dudes just [__]
doing karate [__] jumping over
barrels and [__] was that the video of
them doing the like I don't know if it
was a joke or not but it was like a
video of them doing like jumping jacks
that but like obstacle courses and like
them training like was that I don't know
if that was a fake video but I remember
seeing that going around how was the
cinematography it looked just it looked
like a just a steady cam like just no
but there's there's it's like you know
how we have our army commercials right
where dudes are just like repelling off
whatever like they're doing stuff like
that and you're just like what the [__]
so to me I'm like imagine being a guy
that that grew up in a country where you
feel like you don't belong and then you
watch these videos and then maybe
they're the same religion as you and you
get made fun of your religion and all
these things right and it gives you a
space to go like oh yeah we're [__]
cool too that's what's dangerous because
that's how they recruit everybody even
kids in those areas right like they they
grow up and they're like man I see all
these [__] bombs here you know
Americans are born own up our [__] and
then they're like oh guess what you
could join us we're actually like
competing against America that's
dangerous and we'll send you to college
and if the video Loops perfectly back
into it again [__] oh transitions they
got good Transitions and that's why
three top reasons to join Isis
[Music]